so here's a story that's been kind of
Forgotten but Toria Newland who was the
driving force behind the war in Ukraine
helped start the war in Ukraine in
January he threatened to blow up the
Nordstrom pipelines so that Russia
couldn't send gas to Europe remember
this
I want to be clear with you today if
Russia invades Ukraine one way or
another Nordstrom 2 will not move
forward
so then in September somebody blew up
the pipelines and that was the biggest
man-made environmental disaster in
history if you worried about climate
change you should be in tears because
the amount of carbon that emitted into
the atmosphere so it was pretty obvious
to us the bite Administration was
involved in this we said that and we
were immediately denounced by the entire
left and the entire media's agents of
Putin
why are they doing that and by the way
when we actually joined this war enforce
what will they do to anyone who objects
to it oh they're going to punish people
you watch
but with this in mind we were a little
bit surprised to see Toria Newlin
essentially admit last week that she did
it watch this
Senator Cruz like you I am and I think
the administration is very gratified to
know that Nordstrom 2 is now as you like
to say a hunk of metal at the bottom of
the sea
oh she's excited about it when it
happened they said we we're upset about
it we have no idea who did this and if
you think we had a hand in it you're
Putin what are we watching here Chelsea
gabbard is a former presidential
candidate who joins us tonight
Congressman thank you so much for coming
on
um so now they're basically admitting it
and nobody is saying anything why
I think there's two really important
things for the American people to take
away from what you have just outlined
here number one is that statement from
Victoria Newland just exposed her and
the administration's truth which is that
they have been lying to us all along
about this there's no way the United
States was not either involved or knew
about this or at the very minimum
approved it so they've been lying to us
they've been deceiving us saying hey
look the United States had absolutely
nothing to do with this while also
trying to sell us the Absurd lie that
well of course Russia somehow bombed
their own exploded their own energy
infrastructure to hurt their own
economic interests that it just shows
how stupid they think we are that we
would buy such a an absurd argument
they're lying to us shows us yet again
that we can't trust anything that
they're saying we can't trust any these
narratives that are coming out of the
mainstream media the second thing that's
important to recognize that is very
dangerous is that they are setting a
precedent through what her statements
are and their actions that now that it
is acceptable to go and uh essentially
use sabotage against infrastructure as
an acceptable strategy so we have to
look at our own vulnerabilities in this
area whether it's the undersea cables
our communication systems our financial
systems our own power grid and Energy
System vulnerabilities the list goes on
and on
the argument is very clear hey look if
it's okay to to go after and and bomb
and Destroy Russia's oil and gas
infrastructure why would it not then be
okay for someone else to come and attack
our own exploit our own vulnerabilities
here so this is the position that the
warmongers in Washington have put us
into we the American people all in the
name of saying hey we're doing this to
protect you we're trying to protect
democracy but their actions are making
us less safe and undermining our
democracy because we cannot have a
functioning democracy if we can't trust
what our leaders are telling us
well and they don't care about democracy
at all but mark my word no anyone who
calls them out on their lives they've
already denounced you for example as a
disloyal American who serves our country
in uniform
if this war accelerates they will go
after you and everyone else has called
them on their lies
it's that's where it's up to the
American people we're we're the only
like where is their hope the hope lies
in our hands to fire get rid of these
throw these these lying warmongering
politicians out of office and stop
listening to the crap the mainstream
media and big Tech is putting out and
take a stand for the truth for our
country and for our security and freedom
amen great to see you tonight thank you
thanks Tucker subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight